you watch Tom Brady there's no way he
backs down from challenge
I hate Tom Brady I want to be the best I
can be
what's that believe nation its Evan this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine and help you
believe in your Michael Jordan level
talent today we asked a fun question is
Tom Brady the greatest quarterback of
all time Michael Phelps LeBron and Gary
Vee have an answer also if you want to
know what Gary Vee and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my to
54 confident series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link is in the
description below the reason people
aren't patient is they value other
people's opinions too much I'm not
afraid to dream as big as I can not
afraid to think of things that nobody
thinks of I'm not afraid to attempt them
either I've never backed down from
challenge you watch Tom Brady there's no
way he backs down from a challenge where
we're chasing isn't just about being
great what we're chasing is about being
the greatest of all time to see Tom you
know right now at 39 and playing some of
the best football anybody has ever seen
not just him you can't say he's playing
some of the best football at age 39 that
we ever seen at that age no he's playing
some of the best football that people
have ever seen at any age so that's very
inspiring you see Tom Brady trying to
win his fifth Super Bowl first
quarterback ever
it's pretty incredible Tom Brady's
legacy is one word Jenny I like Hitler
more than Tom yeah that's where I what
just want everybody understand that's my
truth
I hate Tom Brady i Gary Vaynerchuk hate
you understand there's real life and
then there's the Jets to me it's very
simple everything in real life and
everything in real life 99% of my life
is very good I'm a good guy I do the
right thing I don't say ludicrous things
like I just said good guy in Jets life
let me give you a good one in Jets life
cuz you have a letter day this is great
in real and Jets life let me give you a
great story I don't know seven years ago
at the Meadowlands just walking
eleven-year-old boy maybe nine walking
by with a Brady Jersey I checked him
this is literally child abuse I check a
kid I check him I bump into him he goes
into the fence he goes into that his dad
looks at me like ready I go what the
[ __ ] are you gonna do about it guys you
don't understand I get it I get it I get
it when I punch the Dolphins like god
yeah the pits whoa ready Pittsburgh game
Jets are playing Pittsburgh the Jets
miraculously in this season when four or
five games miraculously beat a very good
Pittsburgh team at home so Pittsburgh
for anybody knows the NFL they travel
half the stadium Steeler fans I don't
like when people come to my house and
disrespect me this 87 year old man is
rocking up the stairs now stick with me
stick with me he's 87 he's high Tyler
was a he's 87 guys
he he's walking up the stairs slowly
right the Jets have clearly won it's
late fourth quarter twenty three six I
stand up and I go hey old man now you're
finished right everybody hears me hey
old man you're
finish your healers are him and then I
go and I don't mean the game happened so
so look I feel like ah you're an abusive
jet I'm a very bad person
I do want on the Jets I do let's move on
before I lose all my fans real quick I
didn't mean it everyone I mean like my
great-great grandparents got killed like
buried themselves so please before I
have to spend an hour and a half on
Twitter apologizing I hope everybody
understood the tongue-in-cheek of that
but I do hate Tom Brady at a level that
is ridiculously uncomfortable when
you're called the greatest quarterback
of all time by just about every sports
writer can you allow yourself to
internally interpret what that means to
be the best today over the back of all
time I don't like it I don't like when
people say it and you don't like that no
I don't like it at all why well I don't
feel that way you know I'm not attached
to that feeling you know I don't care
whether people think that or not you
know I want to be the best I can be I
know what I go out there it's not to
compare myself to this guy or that guy
it's everyone's good everyone plays good
it's what you say even at the very
beginning of the book oh I think when
you first went to Michigan you wanted to
compete you want a competitor you know
I'm your guy yeah I'm paraphrasing there
so as a person who loves to compete as
much as you do yeah and loves that you
get a thrill out of out of actually the
competition it must feel particularly
good to then be considered the very best
yeah I don't I still feel like I'm in it
I still feel like I'm doing it I still
feel like there's still more to be
accomplished I was practicing the last
two days like you know working on my
technique on my fundamentals on my all
the things with my training that I still
feel like I can be better be a
percentage better I played a long time
mm-hmm it's not like you go hey man I'm
gonna become ya know something different
no I am what I am I know my strengths
I've improved on some of the weaknesses
and I still think I want to go out there
and compete and play with a bunch of 22
year old city you know it's still a lot
of fun now I've got a really special
bonus clip of some of Tom Brady's
greatest plays of all time that
think you're gonna really enjoy but
before that question of the day I want
to know what do you think is Tom Brady
the greatest quarterback of all time or
not leave it down in the comments below
Grady touchdown Julian Edelman
came back to it al it came right back to
it
this one took pleasure
[Applause]
[Music]
Steve and Brady still has the football
one effect to the endzone touchdown New
England
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
clean up perfectly
Michell water
[Applause]
Edelman
here's Hammond owner down there too
first down Grady underneath finds white
white down inside the James White
[Applause]
see the clock here not even seven to go
here a hits Amendola first out on second
effort then Brandon LaFell 23-yard
touched it in the bucket right there you
talk about it ray this is not that's a
lateral go back to Brady now for anyone
his aunt cut a touchdown right over
Anthony Smith bringing with time
[Music]
[Applause]
touchdown
[Applause]
and they snap it and
you can see EE
[Applause]
doing things Britney makes it look like
you got some confusion they direct snap
it
I believe the James White he tosses it
to Danny Amendola
[Applause]
lady steps up trying to run for it makes
a move on
first down Tom Brady how's your head
how's your happiness in his locker
should be television greatest
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that that people need
passion and not one drop of most
self-worth depends on your it's supposed
to man if you guys like this video and
want to learn more about Tom check out
the top 10 it was a success video that I
made on him it's sitting there right
next to me go click on it continue to
believe and I'll see you there when I
watch myself play at times I still don't
think I'm very good I've got to do
things differently and I got to evolve
over time